are we
already in civil war in america
if no what are the chances of a civil
war
happening in america in 2020 and give
percentages
you go first are we already civil war in
america
if not is there a chance of it and if
yes what's the likelihood of that
happening in 2020 how are you defining
civil war
let's pull up the definition of civil
war definition of civil war because we
went through a pretty bad civil war
we did in our country we did but this by
the way this is not this is not me
talking it's a very sensitive topic but
people are bringing it up
and many have sent us messages hey a war
between citizens of the same country a
a physical war guns a physical portal
militia militias built up on both sides
and there's war
do you think we're there right now if
not do you think we can be there by the
end of the year i i
uh sadly that we're trending in the
wrong direction
sadly obviously okay uh you know the the
the better angels within me would hope
that we are not anywhere near
anything near anything like that but i
did see that video that you sent of
black militia obviously the kkk and
neo-nazis or
i don't know if you could run in rampant
that's the video we'll go to the next
video but let's just keep going through
it
we'll see about that video but go ahead
you were saying
no it's it's just uh the fact that we're
even talking about it is sad to me
but i'm sure you're going to show me a
video that's going to show us
a little more enlightenment by the way i
actually don't have i don't have any
angles i'm going with i'm actually
sincerely asking you as a friend
do you think we can be there by the end
of the year
genuinely i i hope not and i do not
think so
and i'm uh sadly but true i'm sure
there's going to be some
a rebuttal by josh saying why we chances
chances of going
have you ever seen anything like this
give me ten percent okay okay fair
enough okay what do you think
well we could go out with a cent 40 i'm
gonna actually bump it up to 55 to 60
percent
and i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna tell
you why a little bit uh later i'm gonna
have them pull up a video
but all it's going to take is one spark
okay have you ever heard the term the
shot heard around the world
yes okay you mean it's it's a single
shot
that can set everything ablaze like one
starts an entire gun fight and what
we're seeing now is we're seeing
armed militias on both sides both
factions
people that are there's there's no
repair
to what's happening right now in my
personal opinion
and we're seeing now a black militia
group the black hebrew
israelites 500 guys fi
500 i mean and when you see the video
pat it's mind-blowing
send it to me i saw this morning these
guys are in full tactical gear
all of them like have assault uh rifles
and they're they're marching and they're
marching on a particular place
uh i i think they they claimed it was
the home of the ku
klux klan but they're marching and
they're challenging these people to a
gun fight
once you've got to that place to where
you've got 500 guys that are assembling
and they're all heavily armed all it
takes is one shot from the other side
and you have a massacre and trust me
looting and rioting that's not even a
thing anymore
now it's guns versus guns and you're
going to see it spread
across the country and people are going
to act out of fear
some people are going to over uh react i
promise you
there's people on both sides that are
mounting up and i know because i get the
messages
in my facebook messenger saying people
that think i'm still in phoenix
saying josh join our militia group josh
we have this group over here
here's our neighborhood over here we're
we're like
people are mounting up they're ready for
the people that are messaging you
dude i assume they're white people uh
predominantly white uh but these these
are people that play golf they're
businessmen they're
what is the civil war is it black versus
white was it north or south
i think it's republicans versus
democrats it's left versus right
so it's a it's a it's a political
ideology war
yes it's it's left blm antifa
versus tea party right like extreme
against extreme or you know
but but but look now now you've got the
democrat
that we showed on this last show the
lawyer yeah that's that's coming out and
he's fully armed
and he's ready to go to war is
protecting his house so that's not
that guy's not ready to go but fair
enough i agree with you can you pull up
the link as well to prepare for that if
we go to him
is what cuomo said about him when he
opened it up do you want to weigh in
i don't know my perception two percent
joshua 55.
you were oh oh relax okay
okay well go ahead where are you going
no i thought you thought you're at 55
something tells me you're obviously
somewhere in between me and josh
between someone who wants peace and
someone who's hanging out with militias
yeah
where are you at so i don't want war
well let's hope that that okay
the moment you have kids you do not want
war no
i tell you when you have kids there's
there's a certain thing that goes away
but
you will wage war if somebody threatens
the safety of your family
straight up it's a very oh oh oh oh
you will go places that it's by the way
it's so natural i can't even describe it
to you like i can't even
describe it to you like you know uh i
i've i've always
uh you know i've watched myself to see
how i am about protecting my sister
yeah paulette when paulette would go on
dates and i was six years younger i
would go from i made sure
one time my sister and i'm gonna tell
you the story one time i said so i got
out of a uh
shout out to paulette and see i'm
actually they're happily married siamese
my brother i love this guy's like man
father's day the other day we were
talking we had a special moment together
because his father who was
the walter cronkite of the iranian
community shah's
favorite favorite man to listen to his
voice
sexiest voice in iran
he passed away years ago and we were at
a funeral and i saw the way this guy
handled he called me the other
day and he got emotional he got off the
phone and i told jenna i said i said i
think see i was having a rough day today
i called him back i said hi dudes i'm
doing good so
but anyways my sister is dating this one
guy
and he uh uh was a qualified
[ __ ] of a guy this is many years ago
many years ago i'm 13 14 years old
i'm young so so my sister my dad my
mom says you got to watch this guy no
problem so i go watch this guy now my
my dad is less confrontational than my
mom believe it or not my dad is not
trying to fight anybody
very peaceful guy peaceful guy and they
date
and he screws up and my sister doesn't
tell me anything but he gets back to me
no problem
so in the streets he used to go to a gym
called uh
world's gym off of bourbon off of san
fernando san fernando in
one of those streets and my friends ran
that gym
and my friend called me said he's over
here i said whatever you want to do to
the guy do to the guy
but he can never come back to the gym
again my friends pulled them aside they
had a very interesting
just real quick you're 13. he's probably
18. at that time i'm at that time
16 years old is what i'm 16. he's what
he's 10 15 years older than me oh so
these are yeah
yeah 10 15 years old wow by the way and
then i go to the army i'm 18 years old i
get out of the army and my dad says
let's go to church i surprised my dad in
uniform right
and we go to church i'm at church the
assyrian church
and this guy shows up and my dad is
begging me
you came for me don't do nothing you
came i said no i'm not i'm not
going to stand here like this this guy's
not going to have good time in church
today
he says you can't embarrass me like this
you can't i said no that this is not
about you bro
it's my sister here i studied my own
body language
on how protective i was of my sister of
how protective i was of my
mom of how protective i am on my dad
and then wife and kids dude
goosebumps talking about right now my
rage just went on my blood pressure just
went up 40 50. we're here we're here
the only point i'm trying to make to you
is you don't cross the line with family
yeah okay so let me get to this my my
my percentage is 10 okay i'm not 55
mine's a 10 but let me explain to where
this goes with with this ten percent
where am i with this ten percent
i do believe the most dangerous month of
the year
is my month is the month i'm born
october i believe october is going to be
if you've never had a license to carry
you've got to get a license to carry
if you're somebody that's not a gun
person you got kids go get a piece just
go
to a because it's the pre-election month
just just be prepared every time
you and it's because of the election
what's life insurance you don't sell
life insurance to say you're dying
tomorrow
use a life insurance to say what in case
god forbid something happens
you buy auto insurance not because you
want to crash somebody tomorrow in case
you get i'm just telling you
you don't buy a gun because you want to
go out and put it to use you buy it
because you want to protect yourself
just in case i'm protected here
you know if you've seen some of my stuff
we're protecting the office we're
protected at the house we're protected
everywhere
i'm just suggesting if you got a wife a
husband and kids
and you got somebody that you want to be
feeling safe about
i would suggest you do go buy i think it
was a record-breaking month last month
in the amount of uh
uh ammo that was sold in a long time
ammunition last month being sold one of
the biggest record-breaking months
that we've had in america i don't think
this is going to slow down so it's 10
why is it 10
uh if you can play this video i think
this video pretty much sets it up
you guys haven't have you guys seen this
video or not no okay watch what he says
by the way
for full disclosure this video was uh
uploaded december
7 december 17th of 2019
and december 17 2019 there is no
coronavirus
market is at 29 dow marcus doing fine
everybody's doing okay
everybody's making millions things are
pretty fine seven eight months ago
now play and see what he says here
complete different angle watch this
if they take him out there's going to be
violence in america that's all there is
to it and what we say
now however he leads there's going to be
violence in america
are you talking about trump what are you
talking about i believe
there are people in this country
veterans
there are cowboys mountain men
i mean guys that know how to fight okay
and they're going to make a decision
that
the people that did this to donald trump
are not going to get away from
with it and they're going to hunt him
down
i'm serious they're going to hunt them
down i don't want it to happen i don't
want to see the country go this way
but once hell breaks loose if
if these people in washington think that
they're going to get away with it
it's not going to happen the trump
supporters
are going to hunt them down
that's going to happen and
this is going to be plunged into
darkness
and they brought it upon themselves
because it won't back off
it just won't back off listen they won't
let the people
express their views they voted for
donald trump they wanted donald trump
but they said no you're stupid you're
ignorant you're racist
you're bigots we're not gonna allow your
vote to count
and they've waged war against those
people now for three years
calling them every name that you can
those people are fed up with the dog
they're fed up with it and they know if
if they get away with this there's no
country left it's done
it's finished so
what does daryl celani say when people
have lost everything they have nothing
to lose they lose everything
they just lose them all right they're
going to go on the rampage
they lose their mind they lose
everything you're not going to be able
to put it back in the bottle
okay so so watch this question for you
um
which side is more pro-military
republicans or democrats
republicans it's not even close is that
fair okay which side is more
trained with weapons republicans right
sir
i mean what he's trying to say is you
have to realize that the thing
that i met with guns people that i met
with guns when i was in the military
when i went in my mom hates guns my
family my dad never owned a gun i grew
up in a family with no guns the
one person that owned the gun was my
uncle the guy that was six five my dad
you've seen how tall my dad how tall is
my dad
the time guy i tall as my mom five seven
my uncle's six five so i got my uncle's
height right or milkman i don't know
about but i'm tall
right so now i look like my dad i have
my dad's nose so that's definitely my
dad
okay so it was like i would go to my
uncle's house he had this shotgun like
oh my gosh you guys got a shotgun look
at that right it was long freaking he
loved
rifles i got a picture with a rifle as a
kid
and a dog over here i'm holding two
different guns we come here my mom and
dad never owned a gun never owned
anything no shotgun no nothing i go to
the army
when you're in the army kind of learn
about everybody owning guns and why they
own it right
most people i know that have guns they
just want to make sure you know
they want a gun just kind of like
we're protected we have guns why do they
want to say that to you
i don't want to use it it's just we're
protected we have guns
just know that we have a gun okay cool
they're not trying to put it to use
but i tell you man if you manipulate and
play games
and if this thing when he said one shot
the shot that everybody around the world
if one innocent person
if something happens when there's
crossfire and it's due to politics
the level of momentum on how fast that
can catch on fire
they won't be able to stop it i'm just
telling you they will not be able to
stop it
and what is scary about this whole thing
is the following here's what's scary
about the whole thing
here's what's scary about the whole
thing adam we spent saturday together
and what did we do on saturday
made a nice barbecue did we have a good
time we're six feet apart nice time you
have a good time
great time did you have a good time oh
wonderful josh you have a good time
phenomenal what do we talk about tell me
what we talked about
well we talked about politics we talked
about religion we talked about the world
we talk about the economy we talked
about everything we talk about
everything that
is supposed to lead to what a fight
argument right what happened with us we
hugged it out in the end but what no
there was not even any fight
no no no no we just had a conversation
well you know what his son you're such a
pat the united states hit a record in
june
the month of june 3.9 million
firearms purchased that's what i saw and
i think it's smart and i think america
and if you're not doing it for yourself
and your friend by the way the the same
friend that said this to me
steve by the way he's watched every
single episode first six he says i've
watched every podcast says this is what
i've been looking forward for you to do
for a longest time i want people to see
this side of podcast topic
he wants this he wants podcasts because
it's when steve and i are together if
you ever see steve and i together we'll
go
we every time stephen iriti gets a
podcast okay it's just
what it is you really like steve because
your miami you and steve will get along
very well so he sends me this
and he's armenian by the way okay he
says pat
i've never seen this many people that
are disprepared in case something was to
go down he says and i mean
real type of weapons i'm not talk i said
steve he said pat i'm telling you
real real type of stuff that people are
getting ready with it's the ultimate
insurance policy
in case things go haywire so the point i
was trying to make you before you went
to the record you talked which is what i
read about the for last month here's the
crazy part
here's a crazy part okay here's the
growing up you and i grew up with our
parents telling us to be careful with
who
drug dealers have you ever been have you
ever had a drug deal offer you free
drugs you ever had somebody come and
give you drugs
have you ever had all the time okay but
but how does it typically start
here's a little bit of drug you use it
and what is the favorite customer for a
drug dealer
repeat customer which is a be back okay
i'm gonna come back and say hey
give me ten more ecstasies and what is
even a favorite customer for a drug
dealer
what is it referrals when you now have a
group of people that buy their drugs
through you and i just have to sell it
to who
one person yeah you gather the money
from your friends you come to me i give
you 50 pills instead of five pills
i give you 200 pills instead of five
pills i had a friend years ago who got
caught with
five gallons of g okay he got into a
massive accident he had a hundred
thousand pills of
ecstasy yeah i can't give you the number
i drove them to the airport and anyways
that's a whole different story
here's the moral of the story here drug
dealers
were people that we were told to be
afraid of the most
today it's fear dealers see at least
most drug dealers can get off of drugs
and go back to normal life
most fear dealers who self fear most
people don't
know that they are addicted to fear and
all their lives their dreams their
capacity their potential
it's controlled by fear so what's the
moral of the story here
95 of republicans and democrats
have so much in common five percent is
dividing america it's not a big
percentage
five percent of america is dividing
america it ain't 95 percent
95 of america can go have a nice
barbecue to get and they'll all get
along
it's the 5 so my answer about the civil
war is i think it's a 10 chance by the
way if you're watching this right now
yourself
what do you think are the chances of a
civil war post your answer below what do
you think it is
he said two percent josh said 55
i say 10 percent and i say october could
be ugly
paul what do you think what do you what
do you think yourself listen to this
year
that's oregon too organized i think to
be a civil war
twenty percent oh you that's still a big
number by the way sam what do you think
25 kai what do you think i'm less than
one
oh you are less than one percent depends
on like how
yeah or just in small pockets by the way
carlos at 70 percent
squirrel score td said zero justin said
five percent
calvin kase at 44.4 so there's some
people that are saying highs and lows
but
but look here here to me is the proof
when you've got
groups that are militantly marching the
street threatening people
and the cops are doing nothing about it
it literally shows you
that they're standing back look chas was
just set up and declared itself
its own country and what happened for a
month
they're allowed to operate as their own
country set up their own borders put up
their own protection they're walking
around with ar-15s
like in what sane world do you ever see
anything like this
and yet you're seeing it right now and
trust me the people
on the right because i'm one of them
they're sitting there like
i've never seen craziness like this
before it's time for me to stock up
it's time for me to arm up in in in in
pat
at the core of them okay you talk about
protecting their
their family these people feel if i
don't do something about this now
this america's not going to be around
for my kids and so they feel like
they're inclined to do something
because of the fact that that they're
not feeling like america is going to be
around the america that they know and
love
for their kids unless they rise up right
now and do something question on that
video
where was that who was that i don't know
where the setting was at i couldn't tell
you the setting or
powerful stuff okay yeah powerful stuff
yeah he kept saying
if they do this if they take away
what was he talking about like
opposition to trump whoever that is
are we saying that you can't vote
against trump what is he saying what's
the message you can vote against trump
but here's the difference here's the
difference when you voted for obama did
you tell people you voted for obama
yeah okay people who voted for trump
you know how many of them don't want to
say anything at work
it's a very different energy let me
explain that part two sorry i got that i
insurance company i have guys who love
obama
and have guys who ate obama yeah where
were we at year and a half ago i was i
was at the
trainer trainers you have two thousand
people that i'm announcing two keynote
speakers
in a month of may that i'm gonna have at
the convention uh
in las vegas right at mirage with 78 000
people i get up and i said
first keynote speaker that's going to be
speaking at our convention is
he's going to have something to say to
you guys i line everybody everybody's
standing up they got their phones
they're alive everybody's
two thousand five hundred phones are
live do you remember that kobe bryant
okay flipping out tears crying right
and kobe's giving a message right and
kobe goes to the convention crushes it
if you've not watched
that interview it's a sick interview
right yeah right hobbies last great
interview right i mean
many call of duty right after that i
announce
president for 10 years i've been saying
we're gonna have a president speak at
our event i announced president
george w bush you ready for the reaction
yeah
some people couldn't believe it they
passed that they were so excited some
people were like
yeah i have people in our company
that'll tell me whisper to me pat just
saying i
voted for trump but i can't say it
publicly because my organization is full
of latinos
hey pat i voted for trump i have blacks
latinos
asians who voted for trump publicly we
have one guy named ricky
if you've not heard ricky if you've not
heard ricky speaking ricky's got zero
filters okay
and ricky is the kind of guy that if you
try to control his voice he doubles that
even more that's how he is right shout
out to ricky's
last one he does something in the
marketplace nobody's ever done before he
and his wife erica quality people
at a whole different level he comes out
and he's public about it
most people are not so when you ask him
they're public about what
he's public about the fact that he
supports trump he's very public about it
and by the way he doesn't like every
he doesn't like everything that trump
did but he's supportive of what trump's
doing right as a lover
yeah okay so by the way ricky loves you
okay ricky was following you way before
you were here okay
here's the moral of the story when you
can't publicly say who you support
because you're worried about losing a
job it's a problem
either side that's that's the only thing
totally you know the day we got a tax
cut here
and and uh it was i don't know what year
was 2017 or 27 when
when we got the tax cut i pulled
everybody employee into my office
they came in here i said i got news for
you guys they said what i said for every
month you've been here with me that's
been working with me
i'm giving you a hundred dollar bonus
they're like what so yeah
for every month you've been working here
you're getting a hundred dollar bonus if
you've been here for more than for 12
months guess what
1200 bucks if you've been here for four
months guess what 400
oh my gosh they started getting i said
don't thank me
thank the tax cuts the tax cuts gave me
that money
so i'm giving you the money and here's
the bonus for you
oh i don't know that way i explained the
basics of math
i'm doing it because if the tax cuts are
being passed down to me i'm passing it
out to you
most people are afraid today and that's
not a good place to be we shouldn't be
afraid to say
who you voted for this is why they call
them the silent majority you know that's
why they call it the silent majority so
by the way you brought up a topic this
last week actually i think i brought it
up to you
a guy sends me a video and says pat uh
three of your videos were played on
anonymous
do you know these guys i'm like on what
on anonymous
you know what anonymous i don't know if
you've heard of have you seen any of the
anonymous videos
you know when they're gone this is your
comment so today we're gonna
that kind of voice you know the the
rattler they're they're the ones that
actually
leaked a lot of the assange emails a lot
of it
so apparently three of our videos were
put on their channel 3.3 million
subscribers
are you linked to an amazon buddy i
never met anybody from anonymous i've
never worn a mask anonymous i don't know
anybody from anonymous
but then others sent messages talking
about the number
what if ken in i.t is anonymous
so but but the thing that's been coming
up a lot is
q anonymous q anon
right and what is it the number 17 or
the number is it 17 or 19. i don't know
what the number is it's it's a
no no what letters q is number 17 a b c
d
a b c d e f g h i j k
l m n o p q 17 and everything's about 17
17 17.
and how q anon behind closed door is
doing something to bring down the deep
state and all this other stuff
and the conspiracy you know you know
media's calling a conspiracy theorist
trump supporters all this other stuff
what do you
mr josh fearstein know about q anon that
you want to reveal america with
our audience some smirk on this one
because people said talk about q anon i
said okay
i'm gonna go buy a gun real quick i'll
be right back
i got a couple for sale for you worry
this is the uh
what what uh what was the name of the
person that was
like throat the uh deep throat
by the way you know you know michael
franzis and sonny francis funded that
movie just so you know
really it's a mob funded movie deep
throat really
wow okay so nothing to do with politics
it's just it's a very deep topic but go
ahead we're talking about the uh
the people or the richard nixon uh no no
no
it's it's a i'm talking about the porno
movies oh okay but go ahead just so you
know porno is when the
guy okay okay um shout out to our
sponsor go ahead you want to do this
next sponsor
so it's a bang bro there's look
there's a lot of stuff out there i'm not
sure how much
q's gotten right how much q has gotten
wrong again the problem with
with q is that you don't know what's q
and what's not because the second that
you get someone that comes out with some
information
and there's seemingly some stuff in that
is ins legit
inside yeah you know info but then what
you get is a lot of
copycats that start calling themselves
cue and then they start making
wild wild predictions and based on the
stuff that has happened people start
sharing them
so look do i think that q's real i do
i do think that there's somebody that's
on the inside probably on the military
intelligence side
uh because we have seen some information
that's come out that
nobody else would have known so do i
think that there's an insider yes
uh do i think that everybody that claims
to be cue is cue
no and so that you think they are trying
to bring the
the deep state down and there's military
people involved
yes are you are you assuming like the
religion stuff or are you saying 100
percent you know
[Music]
oh he went there do do
i believe that that trump is part of an
agenda to bring down
the deep state one million percent oh
seriously yes